[Musik]
pleite eines reiseriesen der britische
tourismuskonzern thomas cook ist
insolvent hunderttausende urlauber
bekommen das zu spüren wutrede beim
weltklimagipfel aktivistin greta tonwerk
wirft den staats und regierungschefs zu
wenig engagement im kampf gegen den
klimawandel vor um einen
raumfahrtpionier sigmund jähn der erste
deutsche im all stirbt im alter von 82
jahren
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und ein
herzliches willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem montag
kristin otto ist auch dabei für den
sport sehr gern guten abend es ist eine
pleite mit weitreichenden folgen in der
nacht hat der britische reisekonzern
thomas cook seinen betrieb eingestellt
jetzt bangen 21.000 mitarbeiter um ihre
jobs
urlaubsregionen um ihre zukunft und
600.000 touristen weltweit sitzen im
ausland fest oder können erst gar nicht
los derzeit sind allein 140.000 deutsche
urlauber mit thomas cook oder seinen
unternehmenstöchtern unterwegs dazu
zählen neckermann reisen thomas cook
signature öger tours bucher reisen und
air marin sowie die fluggesellschaft
condor
condor fliegt vorerst weiter braucht
aber dringend geld und hat einen
überbrückungskredit bei der
bundesregierung beantragt andrea meuser
blick zunächst nach mallorca
wie gut dass es die helfer in den gelben
westen gibt auf dem flughafen von palma
de mallorca hielt sich das chaos dank
ihrer arbeit heute in grenzen
ich finde sie haben einen guten job
gemacht sie haben uns am morgen vom
hotel geholt und hierher gebracht
wir haben heute morgen im fernsehen von
der pleite gehört mehr wissen wir nicht
600.000 reisende sollen weltweit
betroffen seien 150.000 davon sind
briten und deren regierung hat am morgen
versprochen sie heimzuholen
es ist eine riesige aufgabe wir werden
150.000 menschen helfen in den nächsten
stunden fangen wir an sie nach hause zu
ziehen
für 140.000 deutsche ist die situation
unsicherer
so haben die deutschen töchter von
thomas cook zwar noch keine insolvenz
beantragt aber den verkauf von reisen
schon eingestellt wenn ein
insolvenzantrag gestellt wird und das
wird vielleicht in den nächsten zwei
tagen der fall sein dann stehen die
verbraucher wieder vor einem großen
problem nämlich wie bekomme ich das geld
zurück und wie komme ich überhaupt wenn
ich schon los geflogen werden wie komme
ich zurück
für pauschaltouristen gilt die ganze
reise als im hotel und flug aus einer
hand das bietet mehr sicherheit fahren
wir zurück befördert werden und vor
allem man kriegt den reisepreis wenn man
noch nicht losgeflogen ist
und man kriegt die kosten erstattet wenn
man schon im urlaubsgebiet ist die
versicherungssumme zum schutz
pauschalreisen da ist auf 110 millionen
euro pro veranstalter und jahr gedeckelt
ob das reicht weiß keiner
und wer einzelbausteine gebucht hat
steht ohnehin schlechter da und dann
gibt es da noch die thomas cook tochter
condor noch fliegt sie darf reisende
diva thomas cook gebucht haben von
deutschland aus aber nicht mehr
befördern
vor allem haben wir den flug ja auch
schon bezahlt also konto hat ja auch das
geld schon bekommen für sowohl hin- und
rückflug und trotzdem heißt es ja sie
können uns nicht mitnehmen so der
flieger hebt jetzt gerade wahrscheinlich
in den nächsten paar minuten ab ohne uns
sitzplatzreservierung für uns vier ist
da aber halt die plätze leer
trotz aller unklarheiten condor will
weiter fliegen und hat deshalb heute bei
der bundesregierung einen
überbrückungskredit beantragt die
antwort steht allerdings noch aus
kavallerie halle an der börse in
frankfurt warum ist dieser
überbrückungskredit jetzt so wichtig für
condor
ja weil es jetzt eng werden könnte
obwohl die konnte das muss man schon
dazusagen profitabel fliegt aber
aufgrund der pleite von thomas cook muss
sie jetzt vielleicht rechnungen sofort
begleichen für die sie unter normalen
umständen mehr zeit gehabt hätte um
engpässe zu vermeiden braucht sie daher
den kredit von der bundesregierung auch
gehen ihr durch die insolvenz der mutter
etwa ein fünftel der passagiere verloren
und es könnten noch mehr werden
reiseveranstalter und privatleute
könnten sich schließlich mit buchungen
zurückhaltend aus sorge dass die airline
vielleicht ihr geschäft bald einstellen
muss noch kurz zur thomas cook was hat
diesen 178 jahre alten konzern ins
straucheln gebracht der immense
schuldenberg fast zwei milliarden euro
hatten sich aufgetürmt wegen mehrerer
zukäufe zum falschen zeitpunkt und am
ende ist thomas cook an den hohen zinsen
für die schulden zusammengebrochen
außerdem sind die buchungszahlen
zurückgegangen wegen des drecks it und
der europaweiten hitzewelle sind einfach
weniger menschen ins ausland geflogen
und eine problem waren vor drei jahren
auch die politischen unsinn
einheiten in der türkei und das ist
einer der wichtigsten märkte für thomas
cook also da kam schon einiges zusammen
dankeschön für diese information von
valerie haller aus frankfurt die
insolvenz und die folgen was sie wissen
müssen wenn sie demnächst fliegen wollen
dazu gleich mehr bei wiso und jederzeit
auf heute.de dort lesen sie unter
anderem welche auswirkungen die
thomascook pleite auf die
urlaubsregionen hat nach new york wer
keine konkreten klimaschutzmaßnahmen zu
vermelden hat darf gar nicht erst ans
mikrofon
so hatte es un-generalsekretär görisch
vor dem klimagipfel verfügt
bundeskanzlerin merkel durfte reden über
den frisch geschlossenen nationalen
klimapakt den emotionalsten auftritt
aber hatte eine junge frau die die
mächtigen seit einem jahr das fürchten
lehrt aus new york johannes hano es war
eine bewegende rede die greta thunberg
zum auftakt des un klima aktionstag
hielt mit bebender stimme und tränen in
den augen ein frontalangriff auf die
versammelten staats und regierungschefs
gesetzt jetzt eure hoffnung auf uns
junge leute was fällt euch eigentlich
ein menschen leiden menschen sterben
ganze ökosysteme brechen zusammen
wir stehen am anfang eines
massenaussterben sind alles worüber ihr
sprecht ist geld und das märchen von
unendlichen wirtschaftswachstum
es ging hier um taten und nicht um worte
machte auch un-generalsekretär und toni
gut er ist klar der zu diesem gipfel
eingeladen hatte ich habe von anfang an
die klage macht eintrittskarte für
diesen gipfel sind nicht schöne reden
sondern konkrete taten
unter den augen des amerikanischen
präsidenten der nicht sprechen durfte
kamen dann vier hauptredner zu wort denn
klimapolitik der un-generalsekretär als
besonders beispielhaft ansieht darunter
auch die deutsche bundeskanzlerin die
das gerade beschlossene klimapaket
vorstellte und verteidigte sehen wir uns
und unser land vor allem tiefgreifenden
wandel
es gibt diejenigen die aktiv sind und
demonstrieren und uns druck machen aber
es gibt auch die zweifler und aufgabe
jeder regierung ist es alle menschen
mitzunehmen die frage auf diesem gipfel
aber ist ob die zeit dafür noch reicht
vor den vereinten nationen in new york
steht theo koll theo die bundeskanzlerin
gerätetyp berg und der us präsident bei
einer veranstaltung wie war das
der kontrast hätte wirklich nicht größer
sein können der mächtigste mann der welt
donald trump spielt sich hinten in den
raum für ein paar minuten geht dann
wieder der will ja eh aus dem pariser
klimaschutzabkommen aussteigen vorne
die 16-jährige greta tun merkt ihr unter
tränen die mächtigen mahnt er wagt es
unsere welt zu zerstören wie könnt ihr
es wagen hat sie dauernd gesagt und
dazwischen die kanzlerin die hier als
einen der klima guten gilt ihr konzept
zu hause wird scharf kritisiert hier
wird es lobend erwähnt am ende hat sie
gesagt wir haben den weckruf der jugend
verstanden und genau das will dieser
gipfel seien ein erneuter weckruf aber
dann bitte nach dem geweckt werden auch
aufstehen und loslaufen eindrücke von
theo koll aus new york vielen dank warum
müssen kanzlerin und
verteidigungsministerin nahezu
zeitgleich in zwei getrennten maschinen
an die amerikanische ostküste fliegen
diese frage hat gestern viele
beschäftigt das sei ökologisch unsinnig
und eine verschwendung von steuergeldern
sagen die grünen
die bundesregierung wies die kritik
heute zurück die getrennte anreise habe
rein organisatorische gründe zur krise
im persischen golf da hatte iran den
beschlagnahmten britischen öl tankers
denner in peru nach eigenen angaben
wieder freigegeben mitte juli hatten die
iranischen revolutionsgarden das schiff
von der luft aus gekapert wegen
angeblicher verstöße gegen das seerecht
zuvor hatten britische behörden einen
iranischen tanker vor gregor
vorübergehend festgesetzt
seit jahren streitet die eu heftig
darüber was mit den flüchtlingen
geschieht die aus dem mittelmeer vor dem
ertrinken gerettet werden jetzt haben
sich in malta
mehrere europäische innenminister
zumindest mal auf eine übergangslösung
geeinigt das soll den menschen ersparen
wochenlang vor gesperrten höfen italiens
oder maltas ausharren zu müssen
deutschland hat bereits zugesagt ein
viertel der geretteten aufzunehmen
frankreich hat sich angeschlossen
anne gellinek berichtet
es ist eine geste des guten willens
rechtzeitig zum mini migrations gipfel
auf malta die 182 flüchtlinge die seit
tagen auf der ocean viking ausharren
dürfen auf sizilien an land gehen
italien und malta hatten in den letzten
monaten ihre häfen für die schiffe der
seenotretter geschlossen weil sie angst
haben mit den flüchtlingen
alleingelassen zu werden
in einem vor des malteserordens
versuchen die innenminister von
deutschland frankreich italien und malta
nun einen neuen anlauf
sie verabreden zunächst zu viert einen
mechanismus damit künftig vorher
feststeht welches land wie viele
migranten aufnimmt das freiwillige
verteilungs schema gilt zunächst für
sechs monate und nur für
bootsflüchtlinge
deutschland hat zugesagt etwa ein
viertel der migranten aufzunehmen
frankreich ebenso zehn bis zwölf weitere
eu länder haben ihre teilnahme in
aussicht gestellt wir müssen mal starten
so viel wie möglich beginnen und dann
eben dafür eintreten dass mit der zeit
andere mitmachen und wenn sie nicht in
dieser form mitmachen haben sie ja immer
noch die möglichkeit mit finanzen oder
mit personal die aktion zu unterstützen
der vorschlag soll nun anfang oktober
allen eu innenministern präsentiert
werden
es ist nur ein trippelschritt in der
reform des europäischen asylsystems aber
er markiert auch etwas neues in der
flüchtlingspolitik die großen länder
gehen voran und laden andere zur
freiwilligen teilnahme ein
vielleicht kann das ein weg sein die
blockade zu lösen wie kann sich die
katholische kirche ändern um vertrauen
und mitglieder zurückzugewinnen
das ist zentrales thema der deutschen
bischofskonferenz die heute in fulda
startet zwar hat der vatikan im vorfeld
vor nationalen alleingängen gewarnt zum
beispiel beim thema frauen in der kirche
doch davon lassen sich zumindest die
reformfreudigen bischöfe nicht bremsen
aus fulda inkl
das ist ein klares zeichen der
vorsitzende der deutschen
bischofskonferenz kardinal marx geht
mitten hinein in eine demo frauen
fordern mehr gleichberechtigung in der
kirche
wir sprechen über alle themen kein thema
wird ausgeklammert wir frauen neuen
verantwortungen der kirche tragen das
heißt zugang zu allen diensten und
ämtern also das diakonat aber auch die
priester rennen die mehrheit der
deutschen bischöfe ist gesprächsbereit
ein jahr nach der missbrauchs studie
wollen sie mit laien über mögliche
reformen beraten über einen synodalen
weg es soll um macht in der kirche gehen
um die ehelosigkeit von priestern und
auch um die rolle der frau aus rom gab
es heftigen gegenwind kardinal marx
beruhigt nun nach einem gespräch mit dem
cast es war eine konstruktive begegnung
mit canarias noch mit dem papst und das
werde ich morgen mit den bischöfen
besprechen so dass ich nicht sehen kann
dass der synodale weg jetzt in
irgendeiner weise gefährdet wäre wir
werden miteinander reden wie wir so
ausgestalten noch aber ich sehe kein
stoppschild die beratungen der bischöfe
mit den vertretern der leyen dem
zentralkomitee der deutschen katholiken
sollen am ersten advent beginnen
vom vatikan wolle man sich nicht
einschüchtern lassen
uns geht es letztlich darum dass wir
wieder glaubwürdig von dem erzählen
können was unser leben trägt und das
kann man nur wenn man das eigene haus in
ordnung gebracht hat
die bischöfe werden auf ihrer
herbsttagung auch weiter über das thema
missbrauch reden viele katholiken hoffen
auf deutliche signale aus fulda für
generationen war er ein echtes vorbild
sigmund jähn der erste deutsche im all
mit 82 jahren ist der weltraumpionier
gestorben
zu den sternen startete der ddr
kosmonaut 1978 und wurde natürlich
besonders im osten deutschlands gefeiert
bis zuletzt blieb er der raumfahrt treu
als berater und ausbilder eine würdigung
von christoph des torrent winken
öffentlich den helden spielen müssen
dabei habe er mehr nerven gelassen als
beim ganzen raumflug davor gestand hier
in viel später im rückblick
dabei hatte die eigentliche mission nun
wirklich das zeug zum nerven rauben 1976
geht's los streng geheim in der nähe von
moskau
hier lernt bei den sowjets kosmonaut
rotiert und trainiert bis zur
belastungsgrenze dann im sommer 78 er
und ein sowjetischen rauch in den orbit
bis zum andocken an der raumstation die
luke klemmt keiner weiß wie weiter doch
irgendwie klappt es gerade so und ein
ehemaliger kampfflieger aus
morgenröthe-rautenkranz schreibt für die
ddr geschichte
dort wird der triumph ein
fernsehereignis schneller im all als
westdeutschland sozialismus schlägt
kapitalismus wer die zeit miterlebt hat
ahnt was das für beide seiten bedeutete
zurück bei der landung stürmte am boden
die kapsel überschlägt sich mehrfach
jens wirbelsäule wird gestaut lebenslang
bleibt der schaden aber er lächelt
darüber hinweg behält es für sich
typisch für ihn und wie gesagt hält muss
er nun plötzlich seien nach ddr drehbuch
straßen schulen alles heißt plötzlich
jene dann die wende einbruch
arbeitslosigkeit und schließlich die
zweite karriere
er wird berater für die europäische
weltraumorganisation esa bringt 15 jahre
lang raumfahrer aus ost und west
zusammen astronauten kosmonauten alle
verein zum mars das war noch so ein
traum von ihm ein brückenbauer gewesen
nicht ganz so sportlich russland müssen
der jüngsten affäre um mögliche
manipulation von daten aus dem moskauer
doping labor mit weiteren sanktionen
rechnen
die welt-anti-doping-agentur wada
zweifelt an der echtheit der
übermittelten daten und hat ein
offizielles verfahren eingeleitet
russland hat nun drei wochen zeit um die
unklarheiten zu beseitigen und auch die
läufer nation kenia sorgt vier tage vor
beginn der leichtathletik
weltmeisterschaften in doha für negative
schlagzeilen
vordergründig ein sauberes top team
hinter den kulissen tun sich abgründe
auf das zdf filmt mit versteckter kamera
wie sich athleten das verbotene ausdauer
mittel epo spritzen lassen ein arzt der
unerkannt bleiben möchte packt aus sie
nutzen epo fallen im training vom
aktuellen nationalteam waren acht läufer
bei mir
wir haben alle athleten häufiger
getestet als vorgeschrieben keiner ist
gedopt wir halten uns an die regeln zdf
informationen lassen vermuten zwischen
kenias leichtathletik verband und der
nationalen anti-doping-agentur dem zdf
vorliegende schreiben werfen fragen auf
der verband hat die möglichkeit
gesperrter athleten freizusprechen
wir arbeiten mit den relevanten behörden
zusammen auf nachfrage keinerlei
reaktion der fraglichen stellen für den
fall interessiert sich nun der
leichtathletik-weltverband risiko länder
wie kenia müssen strikte regeln erfüllen
andernfalls kann der weltverband zu
suspendieren vorläufig läuft der
verdacht mit bei kenias wm zu und der
deutsche sport der feiert ein jubiläum
50 jahre jugend trainiert für olympia
und paralympics mehr als 12.000
schülerinnen und schüler sind bei der
feier im berliner olympiastadion dabei
zu den gratulanten
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
als schirmherr des größten
schulsportwettbewerb der welt mit jugend
trainiert begannen bereits viele
beeindruckende karriere von überaus
erfolgreichen deutschen sportlerinnen
und sportlern echt schön das ist so was
gibt mir die liste hätte man jetzt
glaube ich auch noch weiteres weiter und
weiter zeigen können vielen dank das
wetter noch es soll wieder anfangen zu
regnen davor aber zeigt sich zumindest
zeitweise die sonne ganz genau erzählt
ihnen das gleich gunther tiersch claus
kleber begrüßt sie im heute journal um
viertel vor zehn wir danken für ihr
interesse und wünschen ihnen noch einen
sehr schönen und unbeschwerten abend bis
morgen wenn sie mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer auch im
osten wie hier in berlin wird es morgen
wolkiger und auch etwas kühler werden
wir haben ein regenband über deutschland
das immer schwächer wird aber heute
vormittag hatte es im ganzen im westen
noch bis zu 20 millimeter regen gebracht
es wird jetzt weiter nach osten ziehen
sich mehr und mehr auflösen aber da
kommt ja morgen ein neues regengebiet
erreicht uns im westen
das ist der ehemalige wirbelsturm
umberto ja jetzt ist es ein ganz
normales tiefdruckgebiet heute nacht
haben doch diese schmale regenband das
immer schwächer wird von
schleswig-holstein reicht es bis nach
sachsen das östliche bayern nach westen
hin gibt es nebelfelder
und es wird nicht so sehr kalt werden
morgen früh sind es meist zwischen 6 und
13 grad und tagsüber wird es immer noch
ganz angenehm sein um die 20 22 in
niedersachsen und 22 grad in sachsen
anhalts und 17 bis 20 grad
es wird am vormittag vor allem im osten
stark bewölkt sein
hier und da kann es immer noch mal ein
bisschen regnen nach westen hin lockert
auf aber westlich des rheins ziehen
schon wieder dichte wolken heran und
nachmittags wird es dann anfangen im
westen zu regnen der regen im osten bis
nach aber da bleibt wo noch ziemlich
grau direkt an der oder
der wind wird ein bisschen stärker mit
dem regen und wer dann aus süd bis
südost dazu ja die aussichten
wechselhaftes wetter kann man sagen
immer wieder gibt es regenschauer und
dazu dann wird's am freitag wenigstens
ein bisschen wärmer ich wünsche euch
noch einen schönen abend und machen sie
es gut